Чому Україна вимагає від Заходу надання літаків-винищувачів?
Як, приміром, президент України Володимир Зеленський у виступі перед членами британського парламенту в Лондоні.
Протягом останнього року Україна регулярно зазнавала атак з повітря російськими винищувачами з ракетами типу "повітря-земля".
Незначні українські військово-повітряні сили, які ще збереглися, майже нічого не можуть протиставити російським винищувачам,
каже Юрій Ігнат, речник Повітряних сил ЗСУ.
Стан зрозуміло що важкий. Важкий стан чому?
Тому що літак наймолодший, який у нас є на озброєнні, 1991 року випуску - це Су-27.
Наші літаки, які ми маємо на озброєнні і досі експлуатуємо, вдвічі старші вже за своїх пілотів.
І вони літають на лінії фронту на півдні та сході України з максимальним ризиком бути збитими.
Україна має застарілі винищувачі радянського виробництва МіГ-29.
Скільки саме, Україна не розголошує.
Тим часом російські нападники мають сучасну протиповітряну оборону.
Технології на дві голови вищі, скажімо так.
Російський винищувач, приміром, Су-30 або Су-35, бачить удвічі далі, його радар.
Він має системи електронного захисту, він ракету може випустити теж удвічі далі, ніж наш.
Наш пілот навіть не бачить, коли по ньому запущена ракета.
Тобто тільки можна донести йому інформацію засобами радіозв'язку, тобто сказати,
що по тобі працюють, щоб він, коли вже ракета наближається, тоді в нього менше часу зреагувати.
Російські винищувачі натомість ведуть вогонь з безпечної відстані, часто з неба над Чорним морем,
здійснюючи ракетні обстріли і по українському цивільному населенню.
Ворожі літаки злітають і приземляються з російських аеропортів або з анексованого Росією Кримського півострова.
Багато техніки зокрема зосереджено довкола кордонів наших, на 40 летовищах було понад 700 літаків і вертольотів різних типів.
На тих 40 летовищах, які Росія використовує для своїх атак проти України.
Це і Білорусь, і окупований Крим і також територія Росії.
Українські військово-повітряні сили просять до 200 західних винищувачів.
Франція не виключила поставок своїх літаків Rafale, які будуються з 1990-их років.
Це найдорожчий винищувач.
Також обговорюється можливість надання сучасних літаків Gripen зі Швеції, щоправда, їх не так багато.
"Єврофайтер" також регулярно опиняється в центрі дискусій.
Але найбільш реалістичними військові аналітики вважають поставки винищувача НАТО F-16.
Країни, що підтримують Україну, мають понад 2 000 літаків цього типу.
Експерт з питань України Мюнхенської конференції з безпеки Ніко Ланґе вважає, що F-16 найшвидше міг би допомогти Україні.
Ми бачили сигнали від Нідерландів щодо винищувачів F-16.
І я думаю, що F-16 - дуже цікавий з точки зору України літак, тому що багато країн мають такі літаки.
Це багатоцільовий літак, який можна використовувати для виконання багатьох завдань.
Гадаю, він добре підійшов би для України.
І українські пілоти могли б навчитися керувати цим літаком у розумні строки.
На думку більшості західних аналітиків, це єдиний спосіб, яким Україна має хоч якийсь шанс
протистояти російській перевазі у військовій техніці та солдатах на фронті.
Російські війська міцно окопалися вздовж 1200-кілометрового фронту, захищені російською протиповітряною обороною з тилу.
Річ у тім, що наразі Росія пристосувалася до відстані досяжності України.
Особливо на півдні, де є відносно невелика смуга, окупована Росією,
де РФ утримує цінні об'єкти управління і контролю та логістичної інфраструктури поза межами досяжності України.
І, звичайно, Україна потребує більшого охоплення, щоб підготувати поле бою для наступу, щоб звільнити цю територію.
Це дозволило б Україні вивести російські ракетні позиції за лінію фронту і підготувати територію для визвольних атак на землі.
Фактично українські військово-повітряні сили вже готуються до прийому західних винищувачів F-16.
Очевидно, що потрібно, щоб були злітно-посадкові смуги з бетонним покриттям, не плити аеродромні.
Плюс у Великобританії вже розпочалося навчання українських пілотів на західних літаках.
Пілотування, зліт, посадка. Кілька тижнів - і вони вже будуть літати без проблем.
Але навчитися застосовувати всі типи озброєння, працювати у складі підрозділу "ланка, пара, ескадрилья",
завдавати ударів по повітряних і наземних цілях - на це потрібен час, місце, а в умовах війни це теж важко.
Україна сподівається, що її пілоти і наземний персонал зможуть використовувати західні винищувачі F-16 щонайпізніше через шість місяців.
У комбінованому бою із сухопутними військами.
Аби звільнити наступні окуповані Росією території.
Україна має заздалегідь планувати подальший перебіг війни.
І якщо зараз нагальним питанням є інтеграція механізованих сил і збільшення боєприпасів,
я думаю, що в середньостроковій перспективі, коли ми думаємо про звільнення країни від російської окупації,
наземні війська потребують підтримки з повітря.
Саме тому Україна вимагає від Заходу сучасних винищувачів, таких як F-16.